(paper airplane whooshes)
- What's up, Believe Nation?
(mellow orchestral music)
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
I started the MentorMe
series with the goal
to try to learn from people
who have done more than us,
and by hanging around
them a little bit longer,
hopefully, some of
their mindsets are added
to their beliefs, their confidence,
seep into us to help us become
the best version ourselves.
Today, we're going to
learn from Lisa Nichols.
and how to live a purpose-driven life.
As always, guys, as you're watching clips,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in quotes
in the comments below.
You might win a prize, but also,
when you write it down,
it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- When we talk about living our quest,
I think that living my quest, really,
if I look at it on a daily basis,
it's finding my own voice.
It's finding your voice.
It's finding the song
that only you can sing,
off key or not.
It's finding your rhythm.
It's discovering what it feels like
to walk in your shoes today.
It won't look like it looked 10 years ago.
Living your quest is,
what can I do with my life
so that my life becomes
infectious to someone else?
Living my quest looks like,
how do I make my fingerprint matter so big
that it lives beyond my transition day?
Living your quest is, how can I forgive
the perceivingly unforgivable
so I can love the absolute lovable?
Living your quest is, how do I give myself
1,000 second chances, and every time
I get to 999, press reset?
(audience laughs)
Yeah? Yeah.
Living my quest is not some
ambiguous, untouchable experience.
Living my quest means going back
and healing the little girl in me
so that the woman can be free.
It's going back and embracing
the little boy in you
so that the man can show up
and give himself permission
to cry when necessary.
Living your quest is not
something that you can't touch.
It's not something that requires a stage,
or lights, or cameras.
Living your quest is
being complete and content
with who you are in the dark of the night
so who you are in the middle
of the day is all right.
Living your quest is as
simple as it is complex.
Living your quest is about
giving yourself permission,
say, "permission."
- [Audience] Permission.
- On a daily basis to become
the next best version of yourself.
Living your quest is not holding yourself
hostage to old decisions,
not holding yourself
hostage to shame, blame,
guilt, regret, and anger.
Living your quest is about recognizing
that every day, I can be
reborn to my possibility.
See, living your quest is
as internal and personal
as it is public.
Living your quest is about recognizing
that you have brilliance in you,
and not being willing to
dim your light one more day.
Living your quest means not being afraid
of the genius in you, even
though you have doubt.
Living your quest is recognizing that
you get to sing your song off tune,
that you get to live in perfection
while you master imperfection.
Myth number two is that abundance
is singularly focused on
possessions and money.
Right? It's all about what you drive,
what you live in, how much money you make,
when in fact, this couldn't
be further from the truth.
Wealth is possessions and money.
Abundance is a 360 experience.
Write it down.
True abundance, true
abundance is your health,
'cause if you don't have great health,
life does not feel good.
Abundance is relationship.
At the end of your life, literally,
you will measure the quality of your life
by the quality of the
relationships you had.
All the other stuff will fall away.
That promotion you're thinking about,
you're wondering about that raise,
it will fall away in
the area of importance
when you get to the end of your life.
You will begin to look at the
quality of your relationships,
how your children related to you,
how your siblings related to you,
do you have love in your life.
You literally will start
looking at relationships
at a higher level as you get older.
When you mind them now,
you take care of them,
and I know that for a fact.
I have a friend who's worth $14 billion,
billion with a B.
He was just partying at
my house all night long.
Lee, four in the morning, go home.
He flew in from Canada to
go to my New Years party
because he loves my family connection,
and he doesn't have one.
He is financially wealthy.
He's relationship broke.
Does that make sense?
Abundance is a 360 experience.
It's about relationships,
it's about health,
it's about your spiritual groundedness.
That doesn't mean you
have a religious origin.
It's about, can you release?
Can you forgive?
Can you let go?
Can you be still?
Do you meditate, do you
have time with yourself?
That has a lot to do
with the quality of
your life, that ability.
Visualization is a gift to
your heart and your soul.
It's a gift because, if
the idea is the seed,
visualization is the fertilizer.
It's the fertilizer,
because, when your thoughts
are connected with an emotion,
see, you would visualize yourself winning,
and you would feel all the
emotion that came with that,
and all you're doing now is,
you're not chasing a foreign emotion.
You know the feeling, and now,
you're just doing what's necessary
to get back to that feeling in real time.
What a good friend of mine, Vishen,
the CEO of Mindvalley, who you know,
I did a visualization
with him, we were in Bali,
and he said to me afterwards,
"I never get emotional.
"I cried."
- He doesn't.
He doesn't get emotional.
He's, like, super, yeah.
- He was like, "I cried, I got emotional."
He goes, "I figured it out.
"A good visualization brings in emotion."
He was like, "That's how you do it."
I love doing visualizations,
and it's real important,
in the visualization,
you can't see it over there.
You have to see it right here.
- To feel it.
- You got to feel it
right here, like, it's all I am.
I am.
I am in my dream home.
I am in my dream relationship,
and then unpack what that looks like,
but most importantly,
unpack what it feels like.
When you have that emotion in this moment,
all of a sudden, you stir up something
that I don't think will
ever go back to sleep.
It'll go, "Okay, let's go get that."
What it really does is, it sets up a state
of cognitive dissonance,
and cognitive dissonance
is when you see something in your mind,
and you see yourself in a way
that your behaviors are
not currently leading to,
so your mind becomes
disrupted, and it goes,
"Okay, can we get there?"
- Right, 'cause I'm not there right now.
- I'm not there right now,
and that's not comfortable.
Your mind wants to literally be congruent,
what it thinks is what you're doing,
what it thinks is what you're doing.
When you set up a constant,
and abundant thinkers like you and I,
we do it unconsciously, we
are constantly keeping ourself
in a state of cognitive dissonance,
meaning, okay, what else?
I'm seeing Lisa over there, and I'm going,
"Okay, let me go," while
being grateful for my now.
It's not in that I'm going
to be whole and complete
when I get over there.
I'm whole and complete now.
I just know I'm supposed to be over there,
so let me do what's
necessary to get over there,
and let me evict any
behaviors or characteristics
that are stopping me, and let me adopt
any new ones that I need.
You're super achievers.
I'm a super achiever.
One thing we have to
constantly remind ourself
is to create micro wins
to get to our macro wins,
that we go after the macro win,
but we only look at the macro win.
I want you to look at the micro wins
and get five micro wins under your belt
so you can create your macro win.
That way, you celebrate
yourself a lot more often,
yes, yes?
That way, you can have an indicator
that you're on the right track more often.
That way, your fuel is being
acknowledged more often.
That way, you know you're
on the right track.
Let's get to micro wins, micro wins,
micro wins can lead to a macro win.
Can we agree with that?
I'm showing you how
abundant thinkers think.
To me, you model successful people.
When I was on the Oprah Winfrey show,
on one of the commercial breaks, she said,
"So Lisa, how many coaches do you have?"
She didn't ask me if I had a coach.
She said, "How many coaches do you have?"
I said, "Two."
On the next commercial
break, what you think I did?
I asked her, "How many
coaches do you have?"
She said, "Four."
When I left the show,
what do you think I did?
(audience laughs)
Right?
I hired two more coaches.
Success leaves clues.
I'm going to give you some of the clues.
People who are living
an abundant life now,
you guys just allow this to
be a salve of confirmation.
Then, for everyone else who's
moving in that direction
and moreso in that direction,
these are the things that
abundant-thinking people do
all day every day.
One, we create micro wins
so we can get to macro wins,
and we celebrate the micro wins.
Far more celebrations in life.
You are only going to go as
far as you think you're worthy.
I can push, you can push.
You can have the greatest product,
but if you don't feel
worthy, you will work hard
to sabotage that relationship.
- Every day, you will.
- Right, you don't know you're doing it.
You just think, "These
are the things I need,"
and you're driving that guy away.
You're driving that woman away
because your self-worth says
they weren't going to stay forever anyway,
or self-worth around money.
You have a cap that you feel like
you're worthy of a million dollars,
you will always get to
999,000, and you will stop
because your self-worth says it.
- What's a good exercise or
process that we can follow
on a daily basis, maybe something simple,
to enhance our enrichment and worthiness?
- Absolutely.
I did this for six months every single day
right after I brushed my teeth.
It's the I See You exercise.
You get in the mirror.
Now, it's not necessarily simple
'cause you dealing with yourself,
and as complicated as you
are will be the degree.
- The mechanics of it are simple.
- Right, the mechanics
are very simple, yes.
I appreciate that distinction.
You get in the mirror,
you complete three different sentences.
You want to write this down.
The first sentence, you look at yourself,
and you say your name, so
you would say, "Louis,"
and you complete the sentence,
"I'm proud that you,"
and find seven different things every day
to celebrate yourself
four, seven different.
Each day, you can do the same
thing you did the day before,
but each day, do seven
different things to be proud of.
The second sentence is going
to knock you down a little bit.
It's going to come from your gut.
"Louis, I forgive you
for," and cut the shackles
to blame, shame, guilt, regret, and anger.
In that sentence, you
cut those five shackles,
not the first day,
maybe not the third day,
but by the 21st day, by the 13th day,
you'll feel some relief.
"Louis, I forgive you for,"
and go back five years,
15 years, 20 years,
do that "I forgive you" for that thing
don't nobody know about but you,
go ahead and cut those shackles
'cause if you can still think about it,
it's still in your energy space.
The third sentence is,
"Louis, I commit to you that."
Before you make a commitment
to anybody else throughout your day,
you make seven commitments to you.
The first sentence is,
"I'm proud that you,"
you're celebrating yourself first.
We are undercelebrated as a society.
We look for acknowledgement.
They interviewed 100 executives
that all made over a
quarter of a million dollars
and said, "Would you like a
five percent raise next year,
"or would you rather be
told thank you more often?"
100%, 100% said, "Keep your money.
"I'd rather hear thank you."
We're undercelebrated,
but first, celebrate you.
Be the example.
When I was on Oprah, and
she said, "What do you do?"
I said, "I recognize that I'm the example
"of how the rest of the world
is supposed to treat me,
"and it's my job to give the world
"the best example of how
I like to be treated."
Celebrate yourself, forgive
yourself, cut the shackles,
and then commit to yourself
before you commit to anyone else.
That right there.
- [Louis] Powerful.
- That right there will
begin to fill your cup up
to get to your salsa.
When you talk about
making your dash dance,
point one, you got to be
willing to do it afraid.
See, you might be waiting
for the fear to stop.
"Lisa," I heard this so many times,
"Lisa, I'm afraid, what do I do?"
Do it anyway.
"Lisa, I'm afraid.
"I don't quite know if I should move."
Move anyway.
"I don't know if I should leap."
Leap afraid,
and then gather your
courage on the way down.
If you don't get it before you hit,
you was going to hit anyway.
I'd rather die leaping than on the edge
figuring out how to get the
courage to leap, yes, yes?
(audience shouts)
Yes, yes?
- [Audience] Yes, yes.
- So many times, we're waiting.
We're waiting, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting to get something right.
I see your hands going up.
You guys know, if it's your
truth, you can raise your hand
just like we did on day zero.
You just kind of waiting.
You waiting to get everything in order.
You're waiting, you're waiting so that
everything is in you, it's together.
You're waiting to not be afraid.
You're waiting to have the courage.
You're waiting to have all the money.
You're waiting to lose weight.
(audience shouts)
See, if I waited to
release my unwanted pounds
before I got in front of you,
Lisa Nichols would be the secret.
(audience laughs)
Yes, yes?
- [Audience] Yes, yes.
- I thought, "How about I just
leap with my imperfection,
"and then find my form of
perfecting my imperfection
"while I'm soaring?
"How about I do that?"
How about you not wait to get it right?
You figure out, how does
it look doing it wrong?
How does that look?
Your 80% of right is somebody else's
159% of what they needed.
Yes, yes?
- [Audience] Yes, yes.
- When you want to do it right,
and you want to wait
'til you're not afraid,
and you want to wait 'til
you have it all together,
oh, you made it about you again.
See, Nelson Mandela did it.
He just did it not
knowing if it were right.
Mahatma Gandhi just did it
not knowing if it were right.
Mother Theresa just did it
not looking for affirmation or
confirmation, is this right?
Martin Luther King did it not even knowing
if it would happen before his life ended.
I mean, what are you waiting on?
Are you willing to do it afraid?
Are you willing to do it knowing
that you got so much work
to do to get it better,
to get it more perfect,
but are you willing
to do it inside your imperfection?
Do you realize that, in your imperfection,
you're perfect for the job?
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What did you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business?
Let me know down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Melissa Alexandria.
Melissa, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and doing that awesome review
on your YouTube channel around it.
I really appreciate the support,
and I'm so glad that
you enjoyed the reading.
- In this video, I'm
going to be going over
the book Your One Word by Evan Carmichael.
This is a book that I
really, really enjoyed.
- Thank you guys
(mellow orchestral music)
so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.